local elections are taking place in
thanet on Thursday the 4th of may you
must register to vote before Monday the
17th of April and for the first time you
will need to bring an accepted form of
photo ID to the polling station when you
go to vote
local elections offer people a chance to
elect a district councilor to represent
their local area for the next four years
this video is an introduction to the
role of the district councilor and The
council's Wider decision-making process
than it is split up into 23 different
areas called Wards each Ward is
represented by at least one District
councilor who sits on planet District
Council
District councilors are different from
County councilors who sit on Kent County
Council and MPS who sit in Parliament
the elections on the 4th of may offer
District councilors only
District councilors are elected every
four years and are often associated with
a political party
if they are elected they are responsible
for making decisions within Planet
District Council for the benefit of the
local area
they are also responsible for
representing people living in their ward
in local government
championing local interests and meeting
members of their local communities
attending Council meetings to discuss a
vote on local issues
they may also be chosen to represent
thanet District Council when other
organizations such as trusts
associations and committees
you can see all district councilors on
our website at thanet.gov.uk forward
slash your counselors
Planet District Council uses a leader
and cabinet style of decision making
full Council made up of all 56
councilors makes the most important
decisions these include agreeing on the
council's overall policies and the
council's budget each year but also
appointing a new leader or making any
changes to thanet's Constitution or
local plan
most of the decisions are made
collectively by the cabinet consisting
of up to 10 councilors or individually
by the most relevant Cabinet member
decisions and policies are reviewed by
an overview and scrutiny panel made up
of counselors who are not in the cabinet
all political groups are represented
proportionally on the panel so its
political makeup is the same as that of
the full Council
decisions surrounding the council's
regulatory services such as those on
planning and Licensing are made by
Committees of councilors from different
parties although councilors act in a
non-political way on these committees
you can view all decisions that the
council makes on our website at
thanet.gov dot UK forward slash how we
make decisions
you can also watch live streams of
Council meetings on our YouTube channel
or attend in person
for a calendar of upcoming Council
meetings visit thanic.gov.uk forward
slash Council meetings and agendas
thank you